SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE IN
EDUCATION WE HAVE A TWO PART
AGENDA PART A AND PART B..
THIS MORNING WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH PART A BUT BEFORE I
DO SO LET ME ASK -- TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM [inaudible]
SENATOR OFF HERE CENTER LABOR.
CENTER MALL HERE.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO START ON
PART A THE AGENDA ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS FIRST.
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
EXCLUDING ITEM TWELVE ITEM
SIXTEEN AND ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY TWO IS THERE A MOTION ON
THOSE ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR EXCLUDING ITEMS TWELVE
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY TWO IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER OFF HI THERE LEYVA FIVE
FEDERAL.
AS TO ITEMS TWELVE SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY TO DO WE NEED TO TAKE
SEPARATE VOTES ON EACH YEAR CAN
I COMBINE THEM [inaudible] FOR
YEAH [inaudible]
THE MOBILE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AS TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ITEMS NUMBER. TWELVE
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY TWO IS OUR
MOTION.
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER OFF HI -- LEYVA FIVE
CENTER MORALE.
OKAY.
LET'S MOVE NOW.
TO THE DISCUSSION AND VOTE ITEMS
ITEM
.
TWENTY FIVE MORE ENJOYABLE IF
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD STORE TO MY LEFT YOU'RE
RIGHT SIR.
CHRISTIAN US MANY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN SIR.
A GROUP BOTH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OKAY WHO WANTS
TO PRESENT.
OR HEADS OF THE THIS IS THAT
ISSUE RELATED TO THE THE TH OF
THE TH -- INVENTOR FUNDING
FORMULA OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONHERE IS TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
TO POSTPONE FOR ONE YEAR THE
SCHEDULE CHANGES IN THE SHARE OF
PARCHMENT FUNDING THAT'S BASED
ON AT THE BASE VERSES OUTCOMES --
AND THEN ALSO APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
A FOURTH YEAR.
I'M OPEN -- TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ADDITIONALLY THE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT
TRIGGERED A PLACE LITERALLY BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MODIFY THE
FUNDING FORMULA.
BY IMPLEMENTING A THREE YEAR
ROLLING AVERAGE OF THE STUDENT
SUCCESS ALLOCATION AND IT WOULD
ONLY COME THE HIGHEST AWARD
OBTAINED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR OF
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION -- WE
THINK IT'S GENERALLY CONSISTENT
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MADE BEFORE -- THIS
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY -- I WOULD
JUST WANTED KIND OF WE ARE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
SIMULATE -- THESE CHANGES IN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN PUT THIS
IN A PLACE.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY I WOULD JUST
WANT TO REAFFIRM OUR HOPE THAT --
WE CAN KEEP THE EXISTING LAWS IN
PLACE FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FUND THE FORMULAS IT'S
CURRENTLY -- WRITTEN IN STATUTE --
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TO MAKE THESE CHANGES ARE
BEGINNING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WE HAVE TWO OTHER CHANGES
THAT WE YOU KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
ON MONDAY.
A RELATED TO THE OUTCOMES
RELATED TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND FOCUSING THAT
OUTCOME TO MAKE SURE THAT IT --
ROOF BETTER REFLECTS OUR
STUDENTS WHO COME INTO OUR
COLLEGES WITH CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATIONAL GOALS THE TYPES
ABOUT COMES THEY'RE HOPING TO
ACHIEVE -- AND THEN SECOND -- A
PROPOSAL RELATED TO TRANSFER
STUDENTS HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT MORE BUT WE COM WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSAL AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DIRECTION THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TEX.
RICKARD COLLEGE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE SIDE OF SEEING NONE IS
THERE A A MOTION ON ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE IT'S BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR A ROTH
IRA CENTER LEYVA [inaudible]
GENERAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT ITEM ITEM SIX ONE TWO ZERO
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
VOTE ONLY ITEMS WE WILL TAKE
ITEMS TWENTY FIVE THROUGH THIRTY
TWO EXCLUDING ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
AND ITEM -- THIRTY ONE IS THERE
A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CENTER OFF I CENTER LEYVA FIVE
THE NUMBER OF NOW AS TO
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY ITEMS.
TWENTY EIGHT N. TO THIRTY ONE
MAYBE TAKE THESE TOGETHER
[inaudible]
CHECK.
I AM ITEM.
TWENTY EIGHT IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THAT ARE OFF HI.
SENATOR LEYVA.
HI FEDERAL.
ITEM THIRTY ONE IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CENTER OFF HI CENTER LEYVA
[inaudible]
TOMORROW [inaudible]
OKAY.
NEXT ITEM SIX SIX ZERO ZERO
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW ITEMS
THIRTY THREE TO THIRTY FIVE OR
VOTE [inaudible]
ONLY ITEMS.
AND I THINK WE CAN WE CAN TAKE
THESE AS A PACKAGE CORRECT.
YOU WANT THEM SPLIT.
ALL WE WILL KICK START.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE ITEMS.
THIRTY THREE TO THIRTY FIVE AS
THE PACKAGES ARE MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CENTER US.
CENTER LEYVA BY CENTER MARA.
NEXT ITEM ITEM SIX FOUR FOUR
ZERO UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ITEMS THIRTY SIX TO FIFTY THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS EXCLUDING ITEM.
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN FORTY
FORTY TWO AND FORTY EIGHT SO THE
MOTION WOLD BE TO APPROVE.
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS ITEMS THIRTY
SIX THROUGH FIFTY EXCLUDING.
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN FORTY
FORTY TWO AND FORTY EIGHT IT'S
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER OFF HI.
OUR LIVE UP BY.
TOMORROW.
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM.
THIRTY SIX THE MOVE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CENTER OFF BY SENATOR
LEYVA BY SENATOR ROBB.
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER OFF.
THEIR LEYVA.
FEDERAL.
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM FORTY IS OUR
MOTION.
MOVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
OFF [inaudible]
CENTER LEYVA [inaudible]
NUMBER OF ITEM FORTY TWO IS OUR
MOTION.
AND MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER OFF HI -- LEYVA FIVE
CENTER MORROW.
ITEM FORTY EIGHT ZERO MOTIONS
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL ROTH IRA
HI -- LEYVA FIVE IN A ROW
[inaudible] FORTY OKAY LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM [inaudible] SIX SIX
ONE ZERO ITEMS FIFTY ONE THROUGH
SIXTY FIVE VOTE ONLY EXCLUDING
ITEMS SIXTY AND ITEM.
SIXTY THREE IT'S BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER OFF HI -- LEYVA.
THE NUMBER OF ITEM SIXTY IS OUR
MOTION.
THE MOON FISCAL FARAS HI --
LEYVA [inaudible]
MORRELL.
ITEMS.
THAT'S THAT WAS SIXTY RIGHT YES.
YOU OUT I DON'T KNOW.
REAL I DON'T KNOW.
ITEM SIXTY THREE IS OUR MOTION.
AND MOVED PLEASE CALL CENTER OFF.
CENTER LEYVA.
FEDERAL.
NEXT ITEM SIXTY NINE EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ITEMS SIXTY SIX
THROUGH SEVENTY SEVEN VOTE ONLY
EXCLUDING ITEMS SEVENTY TWO IS
OUR MOTION.
THE MOVE.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
SARAH HI CENTER LEYVA FIVE
FEDERAL.
AS TO ITEM SEVENTY TWO IS OUR
MOTION.
AND MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER OFF HI CENTER LEYVA.
THE NUMBER OF ITEM ZERO SIX FIVE
ZERO OFFICE SUPPORTING RESEARCH
ITEM.
SEVENTY EIGHT VOTE ONLY A SIR
MOTIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER OFF BY CENTER LEYVA.
FEDERAL.
LET'S TURN TO ITEM SIXTY FOUR
FORTY UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ITEMS.
SEVENTY NINE THROUGH EIGHTY THIS
IS A DISCUSSION AND VOTE
[inaudible]
ITEM.
GOOD MORNING ALL THANKS
JENNIFER'S SO STARTING TO MY
LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT SIR.
CHECK HOLD PUBLIC FINANCE.
SAY OVER TEN IN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SEE YOU AGAIN USING
CONCENTRATE SOLELY OUT.
OF THE USUAL SUSPECTS.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
WE'RE ON PAGE FORTY FOUR OF THE
AGENDA FOR THOSE WHO WERE
FOLLOWING THE PLAYBOOK.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND USE THE ITEM.
A ISSUE SEVENTY NINE YOU SEE
RETIREMENT PLAN -- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO MODIFY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. TO REQUIRE
THAT PRIOR TO THE RELEASE OF
FUNDS YOU SEE SUBMIT AN ACTUAR
AN ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS VERIFYING.
THAT OFFERING A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION OPTION DOES NOT
HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN.
AND TO THAT IT'S A MINUTE
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
OF THE DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
OPTION.
I DIDN'T REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
THE DC OPTION ON OF THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY OF CERTAIN
LOW INCOME WAGE WORKERS.
YES MA'AM I'M THANK YOU TERM
ROTH UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
IS OKAY WITH WE'RE WE'RE FINE
WITH THE SUBMITTING SOME
REPORTING LANGUAGE WE WOULD
REQUEST A FEW CHANGES AND WE'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF.
US SPECIFICALLY ON THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF THE REPORTING
LANGUAGE WORD TALKS ABOUT THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY OF LOW
INCOME WORKERS IF YOU SEE WE
THINKS THE WORD SECURITY IS A
LITTLE -- SUBJECTIVE OF A TERM
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THAT
TO EITHER OUTCOMES ARE BENEFITS
BUT WILL WORK WITH YOUR STAFF IF
THAT IS OKAY WITH YOU BUT IN
CONCEPT WE'RE OKAY WITH
SUBMITTING REPORTING LANGUAGE
THIS FUNDING STAFF WILL WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE THE PURPOSE
OF THE REQUEST I THINK SO.
I THINK WE CAN YES OUR LANGUAGE --
THE RESTORATION DOESN'T HAVE AN
OPINION ON THE MODIFICATIONS AT
THIS TIME.
BECAUSE ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
THIS IS A QUIET CROWD.
OKAY SEEING NONE IS THERE A
MOTION ON A MOTION ON ITEM
SEVENTY NINE AND EIGHTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL -- OFF HI.
THAT ARE LEYVA HI.
THAT OUR MORALE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THIS.
IS ANOTHER.
ONE I TOOK BOTH OF I'D I SEE
WHAT I DID.
SO THE MOTION WAS IS TO SEVENTY
NINE AND EIGHTY WILL HAVE WE MAY
HAVE TO RE DO THAT LET'S TALK TO
EIGHTY THAN.
THE SPA THIS IS ISSUE EIGHTY THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S -- MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AS AS IT WAS PROPOSED
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY ADD
REPORTING LANGUAGE -- ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT -- OUTCOMES
AND HOW THE FUNDS ARE SPENT --
REGARDING THE PROGRAM.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
HAPPY TO PROVIDE REPORTING
LANGUAGE WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF ON THE TIMING OF
THE REPORT BECAUSE OF WE WANT
HAVE.
OF HOW THE EXACT INFORMATION ON
HOW THE FUNDS WERE SPENT UNTIL
AFTER ABOUT. TWO TO THREE MONTHS
AFTER THE CLOSE OF THE FISCAL
YEAR SO IF WE CAN WORK ON THE
TIMING OF THE SUBMISSION.
WHICH REQUEST THAT CERTAINLY.
NO COMMENTS ON THE MINUTES THIS
TIME QUESTIONS ON EIGHTY
COLLEAGUES.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
NOW LET'S.
TAKE A MOTION I GUESS THIS ONE
IS ON EIGHTY THE LAST ONE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ON SEVENTY NINE IT'S
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THEY'RE OFF I CENTER LEYVA.
THE NUMBER OF NOWOUR FINISHED
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM SIXTY NINE EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THERE'S ONE ITEM ITEM
EIGHTY ONE THIS IS A ALSO A
DISCUSSION AND VOTE ITEM.
HAVING TO DO WITH TEACHERS
SERVICE CREDIT SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM -- WE'RE MISSING A
PLAYER [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT --
OKAY.
THINK WE NEED TO WAIT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO. ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES NEEDS
TO COMPLETE BRIEFING ON THE K.
TWELVE PORTION OF THE AGENDA SO
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS NOW WE
WILL COME BACK. ONE MINUTE LET
ME FIGURE OUT THE TIME SCHEDULE
[inaudible]
READ THIS [inaudible]
OVER THE IN ANY OF THAT WE HAVE
TO WAIT FOR OUR YOURS WILL BE.
CHAIRMAN IF I CAN MAKE A JUST A
GLOBAL REMARK CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH THE FINANCING THANK BOTH IN
THE BOAT ONLY ITEMS AND THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT --
CERTAINLY DIFFER FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED -- FINANCIAL
PLANNING AND JUST GLOBALLY CALL
ITEMS WERE JUST NOT IN A
POSITION THAT'S FAIRLY TO
SUPPORT THOSE AT THIS TIME --
BUT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF AND REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE SENATE -- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD COURT IN THE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS NOW I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND APPRECIATE YOUR HELP
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HOW FAR AWAY ARE THOUGH JUST
DOWN THE HALL
THE AVERAGE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT AMOUNTS TO THE
NUMBER SPECIFIED CREDENTIALS
OBTAINED INFORMATION REGARDING
PRIORITY SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS?
THE BILL LANGUAGE -- WOULD BE
MODIFIED AS NECESSARY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MINUTES.
CHRIS FERGUSON FINANCE I THINK
BY GLOBAL COMMENT WOULD APPLY
HERE THANK YOU [inaudible]
CERTAIN GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU DAVID O'BRIEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION PROCEDURE PATIENTS OF
NO CONCERNS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE STILL
SORT OF ANALYZING THIS PROPOSAL
AND WORKING THIS OUT AT A STAFF
LEVEL WHAT IMPLEMENTATION
REQUIRE AND WERE ALWAYS YOUNG
GENERALLY SORT OF GLOBALLY --
APPRECIATIVE OF PROVIDING
CLARITY AS THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
WOULD SELL NO CONCERNS PERFECT --
ONCE AGAIN PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE EIGHTY ONE YES MA'AM
PLEASE COME UNDER.
MORNING METABOLISM HAVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE ACCESS WE
SUPPORT THE APPROPRIATION OF
EIGHTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS PURPOSE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
WE HAVE A TEACHER SHORTAGE.
BOB AND WOOD COURT TO EVALUATING
THAT ASSN AS PROPOSED TRAILER
BUDGET LANGUAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS.
THEIR MOTION ON ISSUE ANYONE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED FISCAL ROLE.
CENTER OFF LINE CENTER LEYVA.
CENTER MERLE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE.
INTO AGENDA PART B. WHICH IS.
K. THROUGH.
TWELVE THERE'S SEVERAL OF VOTE
ONLY ITEMS -- AND SOME
DISCUSSION VOTE ITEMS -- I
INTEND TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN --
FOR SENATOR MORALE -- TO JOIN
BACK IN WHEN HE RETURNS.
WHY DON'T WE START WITH THE --
ITEM SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DISCUSSION AND VOTE [inaudible]
AND THE IS.
TO AND ITEM FORTY FIVE SIXTY
MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION FEES
THIS IS A DISCUSSION AND VOTE
ITEM.
ITEMS ONE OH SIX AND ONE OH
SEVEN CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION.
YOU.
ARE AVAILABLE.
GIVE ME A VOTING EACH OF THESE
ITEMS.
WERE THESE EACH OR THESE BLOCKS
.
OKAY IF YOU DO THEN FOR YOURSELF
FOR THE RECORD STARTING TO MY
LEFT TO RIGHT SIR.
CLAIM JACKSON WE HAVE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF TONY THURMOND
TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
I GOT.
FAIRBURN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
RYAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SERRA CORTEZ LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE [inaudible]
MISS CURTIS.
OKAY WE ARE ON PAGE. FOR FORTY
THREE AND IT'S ITEM ONE OH SIX
CHILD CARE SLOTS.
SO ITEM ONE OH SIX CHILDCARE
SLOTS STAFF RECOMMENDS TO
PROVIDE NINETY MILLION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION ON GOING
GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ALTERNATIVE PAYMENTS
LOTS AND GENERAL CHILDCARE SLOTS
FOR INFANTS TODDLERS.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
FROM THE DIET SO I MEAN FROM THE
TABLE COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED JUST ITEM ONE OF
SIX THIS CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
OFF BY SENATOR LEYVA.
THEIR MOTTO SEVEN REGENCY CHILD
CARE DIVERSION VOUCHER PILOT
PROGRAM.
ANY TAKERS.
THE EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
DIVERSION -- VOUCHER PILOT
PROGRAM IS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION OF FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND IT INCLUDES TWELVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
IN ONGOING FEDERAL CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT FUNDING --
TO GO TO ALTERNATE PAYMENT
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE.
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO FAMILIES
WHO HAVE HAD A DISRUPTION IN
THEIR CHILD CARE SERVICES I IT
IS A PILOT PROGRAMS WILL GO OUT
TO TWELVE COUNTIES.
IN THE GOAL OF HELPING FAMILIES
ARE IN A VERY VULNERABLE TIME I
GET THE CHILD CARE THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO STABILIZE THEIR
THEIR WORKING SITUATION.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS A STAFF
RECOMMENDS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL AND REDIRECT FUNDS TO
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT SLOTS TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO STABLE LONG
TERM CARE FOR FAMILIES
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SIR LEYVA.
V. S. PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
IT WOULD ONLY BE FOR THREE
MONTHS RIGHT THE EMERGENCY SLOTS.
BE THE FUNDING WOULD BE FOR A A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME AND IT IS
A PILOT PROGRAM SO IT WOULD.
BE OVER THREE YEARS AS WELL BUT
FOR THE FAMILY WHO NEEDED THE
EMERGENCY SLOT THEY WOULD ONLY
GET IT FOR THREE MONTHS CORRECT
CORRECTED BE A LIMITED TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
ITEM ONE OF SEVEN OKAY SEEING
NONE THE MOTION IS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED IS THE ITEM ONE
OH SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
SENATOR LEYVA.
AGAIN WE'RE HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN ON EACH OF THESE ITEMS FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE AWAIT SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING.
BUT A ONE OH EIGHT IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE --
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED NINETY
SIX MILLION ON GOING.
IN GRANTS TO DISTRICTS SERVING
LARGE CONCENTRATIONS OF STUDENTS
WERE LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS
OR WHO HAVE DISABILITIES THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
THE QUESTIONS QUESTION.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCANDREW
IT ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE PACKAGE THAT THE SENATE
HAS PUT FORWARD -- WE HAVE BEEN
SEEKING EQUALIZATION TO THE
NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE SO
MOVING TO THE NINETIETH -- IS A
WONDERFUL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
SOME INTENSE LANGUAGE TO MOVE TO
THAT NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE --
REGARDING THAT PRESCHOOL PACKAGE --
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND PRE SCHOOL -- BUT
THE ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE -- PARTICULARLY WITH THE
SENATE PROPOSAL IS MAKING SURE
THAT ALL PRESCHOOLERS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE GRANT -- EVEN
THOSE WHO ARE INELIGIBLE -- TO
BE IN THAT SORT OF THOSE GENERAL
EDUCATION SERVICES -- BUT WE DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE STILL A
NEED -- FOR HIGH COST US
STUDENTS TO BE ADDRESSED --
THROUGH SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE --
THAT FUNDING BEING PUT BACK IN
AS WELL WE NOTICED THAT THE
AMOUNT FOR SPECIAL ED IS A
LITTLE BIT LOWER THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED.
SO IF THAT FULL AMOUNT COULD BE --
CONSIDERED BY THE SENATE AND THE
HIGH COST STUDENTS -- BE
ADDRESSED WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES SIR.
ARE WE COMMENTING SEPARATELY ON
EACH ITEM OR AS A AS A GROUP.
WELL YOU KNOW THEY'VE ASKED ME
TO TAKE THEM UP SEPARATELY OF SO
WHAT I WOULD ASK IS IF YOU'RE UP
TO COMMENT THAT YOU CAN COMMENT
ON ANYTHING YOU LIKE SO WE DON'T
HAVE THIS.
DAISY CHAIN EFFECT HERE SO.
IF YOU'RE PREPARED TO DO SO FAR
I HAVE NOT THANK YOU --
APOLOGIZE FOR THE STAMMERING --
WITH REGARD TO THEIR BRING ALL
DAYS HAVE ONLY THREE CARD -- TO
ITEM ONE AWAY -- WE SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
OF WITH REGARD TO ITEM ONE OF
NINE SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND JEFF BOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS -- WE
SUPPORT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON ITEM ONE OH NINE SPECIAL
EDUCATION EARLY INTERVENTION.
ON ITEM ONE ELEVEN SPECIAL
EDUCATION EQUALIZATION.
I WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THAT ITEM
AS WELL.
WOULD ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER WITH REGARD
TO A HOPE THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WILL INDICATE THAT THIS
IS BUT THE FIRST STEP.
IN A LONG TERM FUNDING PLAN WITH
REGARD TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
EQUALIZATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR SURE.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE OUR
WHOLE SIZER ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF THAT -- WE
ARE IN IN REGARD TO ITEM ONE
AWAIT WE SUPPORT THE POSITION
AND THE RECOMMENDATION OF STAFF
TO REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
REGARDING ITEM ONE ELEVEN WE ARE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR CONSIDERATION OF THE NEED
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
EQUALIZATION.
WE WOULD AGREE WITH THE SPEAKER
FOR THE COALITION THAT THE GOAL
SHOULD BE TO GET TO THE NINETY
FIFTH PERCENTILE BUT WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
RECOMMENDATION AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
WILL WORK THIS OUT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT.
MORNING MIGHT THE ALBERTA BEHALF
VESSELS ASIAN OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS SUMMER TO
THE PRIOR SPEAKERS ACTS ALSO
SUPPORTS -- THE SENATE PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION EQUALIZATION OF
PROPOSED IN ITEM ONE ELEVEN OUR
STATE VALIDATING OUR POSITION
REGARDING THEM -- PRESCHOOL
INTERVENTION GRANT PROGRAM HI
BUTWE JUST DO SUPPORT ITEM ONE
OH NINE WHEN IT COMES TO THE T.
CAL DEBILITY AND HOW TO WEEK.
AND ENGAGE OUR ORDER YOUNGER
ORDERS OR DURING THEIR SCHOOL
CAREER -- AND WE LOOK FOR TO
PART OF THE CONVERSATION OF THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT ELIZABETH ASK OF
ALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL USINESS
OFFICIALS JUST LIKE THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
A WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
NINETIETH PERCENTILE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
BUT WE DID SEE THE REDUCTION OF
THE SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
MILLION THAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION.
DOWN -- TO IT WAS REDUCED BY A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
GO INTO THE HIGH NEEDS.
STUDENTS AND ALSO BRINGING UP
THE BRINGING THE SPECIALIZATION
TO THE NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THESE
ITEMS.
OKAY WE'RE FOCUSED ON ITEM ONE
AWAIT NOW THESE DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED THIS CALL THE
ROLL SENATE AROUND.
SENATOR LEYVA.
ITEM ONE OH NINE SPECIAL
EDUCATION EARLY INTERVENTION.
AS REFERENCED IN -- FROM THE
PUBLIC COMMENT OF ONE OH NINE IS
A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROPOSAL.
SPECIFICALLY THIS WOULD PROVIDE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING --
TO SERVE AND ASSOCIATED BUDGET
BILL AND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO SERVE THREE PURPOSES.
FIRST TO PROVIDE A GRANT TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EVERY
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILD WITH
DISABILITIES WHO SERVED IN A
MAINSTREAM.
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
SECOND -- TO TO MAKE ALL.
OUR MOST FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH --
AYE AP'S CATEGORICALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
THAT AND US OLD PEOPLE FOR L.
CFF FUNDING UNDER THE GRADE AND
THREE TO REQUIRE DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL REPORTING ON
SERVICES.
PROVIDED TO AND THE
MAINSTREAMING OF CHILDREN WITH
IT PEAS THERE ARE ALSO TWO
CONFORMING ITEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS THAT WOULD BE ITEM ONE TEN
AN ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN ONE TEN AS
YOUR DEPOSIT. TO THE STATE
SCHOOL RESERVE FUND -- THE
INCREASE IN EIGHTY A THAT WOULD
BE GENERATED BY MAKING SOME
STUDENTS CATEGORICALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
REDUCES.
THE REQUIRED DEPOSIT INTO THAT
ACCOUNT AND SUBSEQUENTLY REDUCES
YOUR NEED. TO SWAP SOME ON GOING
LCF FUNDS WITH ONE TIME FUNDS
SOURCES.
BECAUSE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY LET'S GO TO ONE EIGHTEEN
BEFORE WE LINK THEM ALL OF AND
PICK UP THE PHONE.
YOUR TALK ABOUT A TWENTY I'M
SORRY I MISSED THAT.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
TO THE MIX [inaudible]
ONE EIGHTEEN SEEING NONE.
CHECK AND MAKE A QUICK COMMENT
MICHELLE DEVIATE APARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- IN RELATION TO THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROPOSALS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONVENE CONTINUES
TO SUPPORT ON THE PROPOSAL THAT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OKAY IS THERE A MOTION TO ACCEPT
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON ITEM
ONE OH NINE ONE TEN AND ONE
EIGHTEEN IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATE AROUND.
SENATOR LEYVA [inaudible]
A ITEM [inaudible] ONE ELEVEN
YES SIR AT ONE ELEVEN IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
MILLION ON GOING PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT THE COOL EYES.
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION PER
STUDENT FUNDING RATES UP TO THE
CURRENT NINETIETH PERCENTILE.
SIR LEAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
LIKE I SAID WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE RIPPLES UNCOVERS.
GOING TO LEAVE YOU OUT.
THANK YOU.
IS IT IS THERE A MOTION TO
ACCEPT DIFFERENT CONDITIONS.
THE MOVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR OUT.
CENTER LEYVA.
ITEM ONE TWELVE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES.
OKAY WE HAVE SOME NEW FACES SIR
THE HIGH SO FOR THE RECORD
PLEASE.
KEITH IS ON DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AB LEAVE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WANTS TO START.
SO ITEM ONE TWELVE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES STAFF
RECOMMENDS TO PROVIDE A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES
GRANT PROGRAM OVER TWO YEAR
PERIOD.
IT GRANTS A GREAT LIMIT GRANTS
TO SCHOOLS SERVING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAT WOULD USE THE
GRANT FUNDING EXCLUSIVELY TO
CONVERT THE PART DAY THE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS AND
INCREASES EACH YEAR THE FACILITY
GRANT.
FROM 50% 275% [inaudible]
SIR.
SO ON THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
UNABLE -- TO SUPPORT THE
MINISTER BEING PROPOSED JURY BUT
WE WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION WITH WITH THIS --
SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP SIR LEAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ITEM.
ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE IS OUR
MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR ROSS I SENATOR
LEYVA.
ITEM ONE THIRTEEN MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT.
AND ONE THIRTEEN IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FIVE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME.
MOST OF THAT IS NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FORTY
MILLION OF IT.
THE SPECIAL FUND TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION -- TO
ESTABLISH MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES INCLUDING --
HIGHER INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION [inaudible]
THIS WOULD -- PROVIDE SUB GRANTS
TO THE EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO THEIR STUDENTS.
BUT IT'S ANY COMMENT.
I THINK MY MY PRIOR COMMENTS
FROM THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTION WOULD APPLY HERE AS WELL
SO NOTED SIMILAR QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN SEEING NONE IS
THERE A MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATOR ROBB HI SENATOR LEYVA.
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM.
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
HAVE ANY REVISION PROVIDES
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND EXPAND BROADBAND FIBER TO
INCREASE DIGITAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AT SCHOOL THAT ARE
CONSIDERED POORLY CONNECTED.
STAFF RECOMMENDS REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT PREJUDICE THE
NEXT ITEM ONE FIFTEEN TAKES
CONFIRMING ACTION BY REJECTING
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT WAS
FOR ITEM.
ONE FOURTEEN DID YOU COVER ONE
AT ONE FIFTEEN IS THAT WHAT YOU
MEAN BY THE NEXT ITEM I IS.
I WON FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND ONE
FIFTEEN ARE OURS AT ONE FIFTEEN
TAKES CONFORMING ACTION FOR ONE
ITEM. ONE FOURTEEN FOR ANY
GOVERNMENT.
ED HANSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
THANK YOU. ELEVEN A QUESTIONS
PUBLIC COMMUNIST OF ITEMS.
ONE FOURTEEN ONE FIFTEEN SEEING
NONE IS THERE A MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
ITEMS ONE FOURTEEN AND ONE FIFTY
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR ROTH BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY. FOR ITEM --
ONE SIXTEEN THE STAFF RECOMMENDS
ADOPTING PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
SPECIFY THAT PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
INCLUDE INTEGRATING SUPPORT FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER
STUDENTS AND CONSISTENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARNER ROAD
MAP PASSED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN JULY.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND ALSO
INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES RELATED TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND WOULD YOU ALSO COVER ITEM.
ONE TWENTY TWO I DON'T WAT
TWENTY TWO TAKES CONFIRMING
ACTION BY PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT FOR THIS
ITEM.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENT THEM.
KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THE SIX AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF THESE
FEDERAL FUNDS A MUST
SPECIFICALLY BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
LEADERS THEY CANNOT BE USED TO
TRAIN TEACHERS ARE CLASSROOM.
AIDES ARE PARA PROFESSIONALS.
SO ON WE DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS
OF THIS PROPOSAL SO -- IF IF
THIS IS FOR OTHER THAN
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
LEADERS IT WOULD BE AN
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS.
STEPH INDICATES THAT THERE WERE
OF THE RESTRICTION AND ARE ARE
FINE WITH THAT.
AND WILL MAKE SURE THE LANGUAGE
APPROPRIATELY REFLECTS THAT.
THE QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ITEMS WHEN
STEPS.
TO DO CONTINUES.
TO HER. TO CONTINUE CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON THIS BUT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD -- TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE MINISTRATION ON THE
LANGUAGE PERFECT PERFECT THANK
YOU PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING MY BATTERIES WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A THIRTEEN
POINT NINE MILLION A FEDERAL
FUNDING -- AS KIMBERLY INDICATED
THIS FUNDING THIS I MEANT TO BE
USED FOR SCHOOL LEADERS AND AND
PRINCIPLE TO PROVIDE THE
PASADENA -- AND THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT ON THE GOVERNOR POST
PROPOSE AND BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ON THESE TWO
ITEMS.
SEEING NONE IS OUR MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
AS TO ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AND ONE
TWENTY TWO BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR RON [inaudible]
CENTER LEYVA.
WHEN ONE SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA'S
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECTS?
AN ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN STAFF
RECOMMENDS AMENDING THE PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE TWO MILLION EACH TO
THE FOUR CORE AREAS WRITING
READING AND LITERATURE
MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE AND TO
SPLIT THE REMAINING.
BALANCE EQUALLY AMONG THAT FIVE
OTHER PROJECTS AND ALSO ADDED
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
SPECIFIED INCREASED FOCUS ON
MEETING THE NEEDS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS CONSISTENT WITHENGLISH.
THAT CALIFORNIA ENGLISH MANOR
ROAD MAP MIGHT SEE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MANY COMET.
KIMBERLY LEAHY AGAIN WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- THIS WE
HAVE WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
DETAILS OF THIS PROPOSAL AGAIN
AND I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT.
ANA A THIS THE PART PORTION
ABOUT THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS WE WOULD NEED MORE
INFORMATION -- BUT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR INITIAL
APPROACH PROPOSAL OKAY.
THANK YOU.
AND WE WOULD A LOT OF WE WILL
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU.
PHILIP ANY QUESTIONS PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ITEM.
ONE SEVENTEEN SEEING NONE IS
THERE A MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
BELOW PLEASE CALL SENATOR ROSS
SENATOR LEYVA.
AGAIN WE'RE HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CAPTION MEMBER ITEM ONE
NINETEEN EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT.
AN ITEM ONE NINETEEN STAFF
RECOMMENDS AMENDING THE PROPOSAL
TO SPECIFY THAT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD FOCUS ON WINE
SUPPORT FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNER STUDENTS CONSISTENT WITH.
THAT CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARN A
ROAD MAP PASSED ME THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION TO INCREASE
THE PRACTICES WERE GENERAL
EDUCATION AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
SETTINGS.
AND THREE OTHER SPECIAL
EDUCATION RELATED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
AGAIN WE WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
DETAILS THIS PROPOSAL -- HOWEVER --
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR
INITIAL PROPOSAL THANK YOU SIR.
TO BEGIN WITH A LINE HIS
COMMENTS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PERFECT.
ANY QUESTIONS GO.
PUBLIC COME AS TO ITEM.
ONE NINETEEN SEEING NONE IS
THERE A MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AS TO ITEM.
ONE NINETEEN REMOVED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR OFF.
SENATOR LEYVA.
AND ONE TWENTY HEALTH CURRICULUM.
AN ITEM ONE TWENTY THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTH
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK NEARLY
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION THIS MAY.
STAFF RECOMMENDS PROVIDING FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO ALLOCATE TO
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION OR
CONSORTIUM OF COUNTY OFFICES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL.
WE TO GRANT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S UP.
A BUDGET HAVE NO POSITION ON
THIS THANK YOU SIR AND
SUPERINTENDENT CONTINUE SUPPORT
TO MAKE PROVISION.
QUESTION.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ITEM ONE TWO ZERO HEALTH
CURRICULUM.
SINGER IS OUR MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
AND ONE TOMORROW.
REMOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR ROBB THANK SENATOR LEYVA.
NEXT ITEM ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE
SPECIAL EDUCATION INTER AGENCY
COLLABORATION.
THIS ITEM WOULD PROVIDE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
TIME NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND ASSOCIATED
BUDGET BILLING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. TO ESTABLISH A WORKING
GROUP COMPOSED OF MEMBERS FROM
THE DEPARTMENTS.
OF EDUCATION HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO ADDRESS. TWO ISSUES
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION FIRST THE
TRANSITION OF CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS FROM REGIONAL
CENTER EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES -- TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES UPON TURNING THREE AND
SECOND -- THE ABILITY OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ACCESS FEDERAL
MEDICARE.
FUNDING FOR PROVIDING MEDICALLY
RELATED SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
YES MICHELLE THE AT THE FINANCE
AND WE WOULD NEED TO LOOK AT THE
DETAILS OF THIS -- BUT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SIR SUPER INTERNALIZES COMMENTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AMINISTRATION.
BUT FORGET YOU'RE RIGHT THE TOP
QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT AS TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE YES MA'AM COME ON
DOWN.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MICHELLE
MCANDREW IT ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION MY
APOLOGIES FOR THE CONFUSION
EARLIER BUT I THINK WE WERE.
EFFICIENT AND OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
PERFECT I'M THIS ITEM -- WE WE
WOULD ALSO AGREE AND APPROVE --
THAT PROPOSAL I SET FORTH YOUR
TODAY WE WOULD LIKE A SLIGHT
EXPANSION -- TO LOOK AT THE PSP
T. UNDER MEDICAID AND THAT IS
THE EARLY AND PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSTIC AND TREATMENT -- SO
JUST A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE INCLUDED IN
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS
COLLABORATIVE THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MY BATTERIES WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS I WE'RE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR BETTER COLLABORATION BETWEEN
ARE DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES.
AND THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S NOT PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- VISIT THIS
ACCORDING NATION WILL ALLOW US
TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE THOSE FUNDS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER BUT PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AS TO ITEM.
ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD YOU SAY
MOTION MY BAD SO MOVED.
OKAY DISTRACTED BY YOUR
SMARTPHONE MAKE SURE NOT SMART.
IT'S BEEN MOVED ITEM ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
OFF HEY CENTER LEYVA
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE
PROPOSITION
.
NINETY EIGHT OKAY ONCE THE
PRESENT [inaudible]
MY PRESENTING [inaudible]
OF I SEE SO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS WILL ONLY
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ITEM.
ONE TWENTY THREE OKAY SEEING
NONE THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVED PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE AS NOTED IN.
THE ATTACHMENT A TWO HOUR --
AGENDA.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT NO QUESTIONS
IS THERE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED JUST ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR OUT BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
THANK YOU ALL.
SO LET'S RETURN TO THE TOP OF
THE PART B. AGENDA OF THESE ARE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS I WILL ROLL
THROUGH THEM -- TAKE MOTIONS --
IF OFFERED.
AND THEN WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ITEM SIXTY ONE
HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
VOTE ONLY.
ITEMS ONE THROUGH.
NINETEEN TROUT CHILD CARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR OFF BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
NEXT ITEMS TWENTY THROUGH.
SIXTY THREE K. THROUGH TWELVE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE IS THERE A
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR OFF BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
ITEM SIXTY FOUR THROUGH SEVENTY
EIGHT STATE OPERATIONS AS OUR
EMOTIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR ON SENATOR LEYVA.
ITEMS SEVENTY NINE THROUGH ONE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR ROTH.
SENATOR LEYVA.
NEXT ITEM SIXTY THREE SIXTY
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THIS IS VOTE ONLY
AS WELL AT ARMS WHAT A ONE
THROUGH ONE OH THREE IS OUR
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL ROLE
SENATOR ROTH SENATOR LEYVA.
ITEM SIXTY THREE FIFTY OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION THIS
IS VOTE ONLY AS WELL AND WON FOR
STATE OPERATIONS IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATE AROUND.
SENATOR LEYVA.
ITEM SIXTY THREE FIFTY OFFICE F
PLANNING AND RESEARCH THIS IS
VOTE ONLY AS WELL AND ONE OH
FIVE STATE OPERATIONS IS OUR
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
UNDER LEYVA.
AS I SAID WE'RE HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN WE WILL RECESS UNTIL
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRTY AND
RECONVENE AT THAT TIME TO FINISH
UP THE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH.
OKAY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
ONE WILL RECONVENE ITS
PROXIMALLY THREE THIRTY PM.
WE'RE GOING -- TO CALL HE ROLL
ON AGENDA PART B..
STARTING WITH ITEM SIXTY ONE
HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
VOTE ONLY -- ISSUE OR ITEMS ONE
THROUGH.
TEN SENATOR MORRELL HI.
ISSUE NUMBER.
ELEVEN ISSUES TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN ISSUE.
FOURTEEN ISSUES FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN ONE NOW.
WAIT SIXTEEN HIGH STOCK.
OKAY SAM ROSEN -- ISSUE
[inaudible]
SEVENTY ISSUE [inaudible]
EIGHTEEN ISSUE [inaudible]
NINETEEN ISSUE.
TWENTY ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO ISSUES TWENTY THREE
THROUGH.
TWENTY SEVEN ISSUE.
TWENTY EIGHT ISSUE.
TWENTY NINE ISSUES THIRTY
THROUGH.
THIRTY THREE ISSUE.
THIRTY FOUR ISSUES THIRTY FIVE
THROUGH.
FIFTY ISSUES FIFTY ONE AND FIFTY
TWO FIFTY ONE NOW.
FIFTY TWO ISSUE [inaudible]
FIFTY THREE HI.
ISSUE.
FIFTY FOUR ISSUES FIFTY FIVE AND
FIFTY SIX ISSUES FIFTY SEVEN AND
FIFTY EIGHT ISSUES FIFTY NINE
AND SIXTY ISSUE.
SIXTY ONE ISSUE.
SIXTY TWO ISSUE SIXTY THREE NOW.
ISSUES SIXTY FOUR AND SIXTY FIVE
ISSUE.
SIXTY SIX ISSUE.
SIXTY SEVEN ISSUE SIXTY EIGHT
THROUGH.
SEVENTY THREE HI.
ISSUE.
SEVENTY FOUR ISSUES SEVENTY FIVE
THROUGH.
EIGHTY ONE ISSUE [inaudible]
EIGHTY TWO I ISSUES EIGHTY THREE
AND EIGHTY FOUR ISSUES EIGHTY
FIVE THROUGH [inaudible]
EIGHTY EIGHT AND NOW.
ISSUE.
EIGHTY NINE ISSUES NINETY
THROUGH [inaudible]
NINETY FOUR NO.
ISSUES NINETY FIVE THROUGH
[inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED NAME NAME.
ISSUES ONE A ONE THREE ONE OH
FOUR ISSUE.
ONE OH FIVE ISSUES ONE OH SIX
THROUGH.
ONE ELEVEN ISSUES [inaudible]
ONE TWELVE WHICH NAME.
ISSUES ONE THIRTEEN THROUGH.
ONE SEVENTEEN ISSUE [inaudible]
ONE EIGHTEEN STATE.
ISSUES ONE NINETEEN AND ONE
TWENTY ISSUES ONE TWENTY ONE AND
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ISSUE
[inaudible]
ONE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANKS SENATOR OFF.
THAT CONCLUDES THE THE ROLE
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE IS
ADJOURNED